number three i have here is salary and
this one is
probably the best uh defined by kevin
o'leary's famous uh quote a salary is a
drug they give you to get you to forget
your dreams
um i remember when i was a salary guy
back in the day in my 20s
what did they start me at 1600 bucks
a month was it or every two weeks i
can't remember but it was uh
it was more than enough to pay my rent
buy my groceries and go out and do stuff
and put gas on my motorcycle and hang
out with my friends and take out girls
it was
fine but um it wasn't going to get me
you know the german sports cars that i
saw the manager is driving it it
certainly wasn't going to get me the
mercedes sl500 i saw the owner of the
company driving or any of the other you
know extravagant trips he was taking
stuff like that
but um you know you kind of level up and
you're like you go get a raise you get
eighteen hundred and fifty dollars a
month then you go up to 2500 and it's 4
000. it's like it doesn't it doesn't
really change the bar that much because
you don't
you don't think outside of any boxes
you're you're still coloring within the
lines you're crossing your t's you're
dotting your eyes because you know
uh even though you got paid today into
friday's time you're going to have
another deposit for the exact same
amount after withholding taxes and
uh employment insurance deductions and
blah blah blah and all that sort of
stuff and it just gets you comfortable
it's it's it's literally
exactly what kevin o'leary says it's a
salary is a drug they give you to get
you to forget about your dreams
do you guys want to top up on that or
anything you might want to add
i mean it's getting it gets people used
to and conditioned to right this certain
limit that set right where it's like hey
you know
do a good job work really hard put more
in here and then maybe we might bump you
up from a four percent raise maybe like
a five or six percent raise right
so
which right if you're looking at the cut
the current plate of a rate of inflation
right it's just one of those things
where you're gonna keep it now i can
take that catamaran trip when i do my
cuba vacation next time yeah well it's a
trade-off between what is perceived as
security and comfort
versus economic opportunity
but we've moved away from the security
and comfort that a salary provides so
there was a time
many decades before my time where people
got things like pensions
and companies offered
a pretty comfortable deal which made it
was was pretty pretty a pretty
solid incentive right for people to take
that salary or that fixed hourly let's
say you know
doing shift work somewhere or whatever
it may be
and they could also afford more on that
like if you look at the 1950s or 60s
what you could afford
on the dollar versus today
you know my mom will tell me about some
so the sweet but then they weren't
classic cars but they are classic cars
today that she was able to buy for you
know less than two g's you know two
grand and the
the this the our inflation inflationary
rate
you can't buy the things on a
single income
in a fixed salary situation that you
could have and not only that companies
do not have the loyalty to employees
the way that they had before so the
paradigm shifted
so if you're
hoping for a salary for security
depends on what you're doing right
because there's certain things like
engineering for example where it's a
specialized trade but even engineers are
smart enough to know that they're there
and it's an exchange between this
company and them
and if that exchange becomes an even or
if they get a better deal somewhere else
they'll fulfill their obligation but
move to that other thing and then
companies are going to do what is the
best deal for them it's no longer you're
almost an independent contractor now
within these companies so you have to
look at it like that and people who are
caught up in that old paradigm and it's
usually people who are by government
type workers came from military right
and that
idea of well i just show up and i get
the same money every you know two weeks
or whatever did we
you said get a teacher
wanted you to be a teacher yeah that's
right yeah i'm pretty sure there's
things that you um
you touched on there that i wanna that i
wanna go back to was the whole um
rate of inflation because you were
talking about cars back in the day and
you know like i remember like one of my
favorite cars is like a 1970 boss 429
mustang with a big ass hood scoop and
all that [ __ ] those things were maybe
like three three and a half thousand
dollars back then today you can't buy
them for less than 200 grand right yeah
like that's what inflation looks like
but back to that point you know the way
that it ties into a salary something
they give you to get you you know forget
about your dreams even if you're getting
a standard pay rise which in most
companies is
usually based on performance a couple
percent all the way up to five percent
if you're an exceptional performer the
rate of inflation is so high right now i
mean you know we were talking about this
earlier on the um zoom call this
afternoon but
you know with some things like produce
it's you know as high as 30 percent but
you know they're saying the average is
whatever seven eight nine percent who
the hell knows what it really is i mean
you always find out months afterwards
but if the rate of inflation goes up and
your salary is pretty much the same
you're losing money i mean you're losing
buying power right and the cool thing
about being an entrepreneur is
it's like having a volume knob it's like
oh i need a little bit more volume i'll
just turn that up you need a little bit
more income you want to pay yourself a
little bit more you just turn it up you
know whenever you need it you don't need
it you can turn it back right well you
can find ways to do it that's the
difference whereas i can't find a way if
i'm working with someone else and that's
my only source
for a raise or something later the other
thing a lot of people don't factor into
is the amount of freedom and flexibility
where it's like when i was coming up
right i knew guys that were making 400
450 000 a year and they had far less
freedom of time than i had when i was
making way less and so it's like you
know they were like man i wish i could
enjoy like all this extra capital i'm
making but you know we're working crazy
long hours we're doing this out of the
other and so that's the big thing you
have to factor in with your salary as
well is the trade-off between you know
how much you're bringing in but also how
much time you have free and available to
you so inflation is a [ __ ] like
the price of gas here has doubled
in the last two years
with the pandemic first hit it was like
99 cents a liter now it's close to two
bucks a liter well to give you a
historical example um in 1960 20 u.s
dollars um has the had the buying power
of about a hundred and twenty-five us
dollars in uh 2019. right so that should
show you right there where right in the
60s 20 bucks
you could you could do quite a bit with
it and then now if you need a hundred
and twenty five dollars which is
probably more close to like a hundred
forty dollars now to have that same
amount of buying power yeah it's been
there's us and then there's them and
they have figured out how to exploit you
trust us hey guys i really hope that you
enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unplugged alpha dot com
forward slash shop when you click
through you'll be able to land over here
and the entire lineup is broken down by
category that it performs best in
estrogen metabolism fat burning your
foundational essentials for health
immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you